sie verzichtet in diesem jahr auf ihr
schönes gemütliches familien weihnachten
mit der ganzen großen familie an der
langen familien tafel fällt dieses jahr
aus das versprechen war doch der wird
schmerzhaft aber kurz dieser ansatz gilt
ist für vier wochen für den november für
vier wochen aber es handelt sich um vier
wochen eine befristete kraftanstrengung
die wir auf die zeit des monats november
also bis zu seinem ende terminieren das
hier ist die korona kurve seitdem
lockdown also seit dem ersten november
gut daran es stecken sich nicht dauernd
immer noch mehr menschen in deutschland
mit corona an aber die kurve geht eben
auch nicht richtig runter leider genauso
beim incidence wert da war eigentlich
das ziel dass sich bundesweit im schnitt
pro tag nur noch 50 von 100.000
deutschen mit corona anstecken aber
davon sind wir sehr weit entfernt
warum hat der deutsche lockdown keinen
richtigen bums
ich halte es für richtig dass in einem
liberalen rechtsstaat in einer liberalen
demokratie in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft man zunächst mal versucht
mit dem mildesten denkbaren mitteln ein
problem herr zu werden wenn wir in das
neue jahr starten dann wir dürfen uns
nicht den ganzen winter hindurch hangeln
auf diesem niveau sondern wir müssen im
januar ein niveau wieder von unter 50
erreichen bei der incidents mit allen
mitteln die uns zur verfügung stehen das
muss das gemeinsame ziel sein eine
therapie den ich richtig wirkt die muss
man doch verändern aber die regierung
macht im moment das gegenteil sie sieht
dabei zu wie ihr teil locker und nicht
richtig funktioniert aber sie verlängert
ihn trotzdem immer wieder genauso
sie lässt alles wie es ist